ou sa lettre est bourré fait par le pi
10 po
[Musique]
ça va très bien merci
il faut ma première fois sur scène
c'était avec mes acolytes de la star
academy la première tournée star
académie donc ça remonte à 15 ans et
s'était complètement l'euphorie
complètement dingue les gens
l'effervescence qui se trouvait dans
cette salle était été complètement
magique
voilà un moment suspendu dans le temps
comme ça incroyable probablement que la
méditerranée quand j'avais 17 ans que je
fais ma première saison
j'arrive dans un village où il ya un
orchestre il ya un public et que voilà
je me lance première fois sur scène
c'était j'avais un copain guitariste qui
est devenu un guitariste après plus tard
j'ai donc un ami guitariste qui qui
jouait dans un tout petit bar très long
très très long et qu'il n'y avait pas de
place ils n'étaient pas large mais non
et j'avais pris la guitare et pour la
première fois j'étais monté sur scène et
j'avais chanté hockey
on peut y arriver le rituel avant de
monter sur scène ce serait de ne pas
m'isoler parce que j'ai tendance à me
paralyser cordes vocales tellement j'ai
le trac et du coup si je m'isole trop si
je réfléchis trop
je ne peux plus monter sur scène
tellement je suis inapte à et du coup
c'est vrai d'aller blaguer avec mes
techniciens mes musiciens d'aller voilà
passé du temps en temps assez futile des
banalités de nos vies de tous les jours
comme ça juste avant de monter sur scène
c'est parfait en général on est dans les
îles et dans les loges et on s'amuse
beaucoup
c'est notre manière de décompresser afin
de d'évacuer le trac alors là j'essaye
de me déstresser au max vous semblez
avoir entendu chanter bureaux son refuge
je sais pas si
si j'oserais mais je je choisirai une
chanteuse que j'admire énormément et
laquelle je n'oserais jamais me comparer
en revisitant peut-être ce répertoire la
aretha franklin choisir un type d'aretha
franklin
juste pour moi me faire plaisir avec des
super musiciens chantent avec un micro
et leur rentrer dedans quitte à ne pas à
ne pas être retenu je me ferait plaisir
d'abord en fait pour gagner le concours
amsterdam de brume toujours été ma
chanson donc où jeff mais probablement
une chanson de brel
parce qu'elles sont peut-être un peu
plus démonstrative et ea c'est
instantané
attends je pense que je connais pas bien
les paroles des alléluia agathe fait
alors je laime énormément il s'appelle
christophe maé il a fait un tube qui est
génial qui s'appelle il est où le
bonheur il est où
et dès que j'entends cette chanson là
mais c'est une chignole elle me reste
dans la tête mais une semaine quoi
minimum il est où le bonheur et l'ailé
où il est haut et puis donc il est où le
truc du coup il est où il loue le
bonheur ça me ramène tout de suite au
titre de mon copain quoi les gens
tellement gentil celle-là qu'on ne m'ait
fait mme nathalie récente est aussi je
trouve même pas mal quand même
cette époque là tout de suite je suis
triste on sait pas tout ce bazar
franchement est-ce que tu fumes avec ça
ce matin je le savais vous avez tous vu
vous êtes tous savoir le singe a menti
je vous dis que je fais ça et la
prochaine fois tu entropa plus petit
thouars talbot
c'est en écoutant beaucoup de musique je
me suis dit c'est comme c'était mon
moment d'évasion à moi c'était très
égoïste en fait ma manière de
fonctionner au départ quand j'ai j'ai
voulu faire de la musique c'était juste
mais moment à moi quoi je ferme les yeux
pour chanter juste pour m'aérer la tête
et c'est en connaissant les premières
scènes que j'ai vu que je pouvais
établir de l'échangé s'est ensuite quand
j'ai eu mes premières chansons que que
je me suis dit ah ouais c'est sympa
quand même des changes est comme ça le
temps d'un concert et de s'aérer
l'esprit ensemble
j'ai trouvé ça assez fabuleux en fait il
ya beaucoup de chanteurs qui mon envie
de faire ce métier c'est tout ce que je
commence à voir à partir du jour où je
vais voir des chanteurs sur scène le
premier s'est réduit ni donc on va dire
que c'est reggiani et et la chanson ça
ce serait entre entre les loups et les
boues sont entrés dans paris et
ma liberté mythos j'assume
non je me moque michael jackson j'écoute
à fond et je versais j'avais des temps
la place à fond c'est pour ça que je
suis de la danseuse du coup j'ai préféré
chanter en voyant ce que je devais faire
ma place mais aller
[Musique]
j'en étais sûr pas ça dans le sang la
chanson qui marche bien dans le film
elle est chantée par la petite porte
épique et à de smet yeux un des secrets
c'est ceaurriz bagdad
socke cornée mais un texte très
approfondies avec eux non mais c'est un
petit fun que tout le monde connaît et
donc du coup ça marche
celle de simon d'heure afin faut la
faire à la diva s'te plaît au moins fait
là la diva faut faire faut se concentrer
people in touch ou faut en faire des
tonnes sinon ça marche fqu
trop trop de vagues qu'il est relevé
c'est mon fiston
elle est hyper du sel là ouais non c'est
clair je peux pas bouger
autorisée
allez chante
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en train de
répéter chaque fois c'est moi ils m'ont
carrément accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
la la la bonté prémont grand jas je suis
prêt de chez près chaque habitant de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star grâce à notre concours de chant
vous allez être ébouriffés par le
picking
comment ça va oh oui très bien merci
fo si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars
vous allez devoir travailler plus dur
que vous ne l'avez jamais fait toute
votre vie
c'était très mauvais ou et joly eelv est
pas là oui c'était une répétition
papa je veux pas faire partie de son
gang ce que je veux c'est être chanteur
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toi son tennis est ministre
chez toi j'ai confiance en toi tu peux y
arriver oui ou non je suis là qu'est ce
qui se passe ici il faut jamais laisser
la peur nous empêcher de faire ce qu'on
aime c'est ce qui l'a bien quand on a
touché le fond c'est qu'il ne reste plus
qu'une issue on doit remonter
c'est mon fiston
elle est hyper nu celle là ouais non
c'est clair je peux pas bouger
terrorisés
allez chante
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en train de
répéter chaque fois ces mots ils m'ont
carrément accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
[Musique]